il est le challenger qui s'impose là où
on ne l'attend pas forcément que ce soit
comme mère d'Ajaccio comme député ou
aujourd'hui comme président du groupe
horizon à l'Assemblée mon invité a
toujours des jouets les pronostics
[Musique]
bonjour Laurent Marc Angeli bonjour
alors vous faites partie de ces députés
qui ont eu une adolescence un peu
différente on va dire dans votre chambre
à l'époque c'est pas des posters de
chanteurs ou d'acteurs de cinéma que
vous accrochez mais c'était plutôt
Jacques Chirac et le général de Gaulle
c'est vrai non il y avait pas que ça il
y avait des joueurs de foot il y avait
des top model mais il est vrai il est
vrai que
j'ai trouvé ça étonnant de vous voir
afficher les posters de la vérité très
étonné mon père parce que personne ne
s'intéressait assez à la politique pour
pouvoir aller jusque là et à
l'adolescence j'ai été pris de passion
pour pour la politique et je supportais
erdemment Jacques Chirac alors candidat
à la présidence de la République c'est
ça c'est la présidentielle de 1995 qui a
fait un peu l'objet d'un déclic chez
vous qu'est-ce qui vous a passionné à ce
point-là dans cette campagne
présidentielle de Jacques Chirac sa
volonté sa volonté
c'est plutôt l'histoire de cet homme
donné battu ce côté presque romanesque
de beaucoup de jeunes à l'époque j'ai
été séduit par son discours sur la
fracture sociale aussi d'accord parce
que il y avait cet aspect là considéré
effectivement qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de problèmes dans le pays qui
n'avaient pas été réglé j'étais né en
1980 juste avant l'élection de François
mitter dans la présidence de la
République j'avais envie de changement
aussi et cet homme ce physique cette
statue et les difficultés qu'il a
rencontrées pour arriver jusque là mon
séduite vous savez le côté homme trahi
par ses proches par ses amis et compte
de Monte-Cristo comme je le dis souvent
que je disais d'ailleurs à l'époque en
même temps donc c'est un peu romanesque
ça m'avait attiré alors à la
présidentielle suivante il se trouve que
Jacques Chirac est venu tenir un meeting
dans votre propre ville Ajaccio en 2002
on va revoir un extrait de son discours
ce jour-là l'accord a besoin de bien
d'autres choses que d'un rafistolage
institutionnel qu'il la placerait en
marge de la République
la Corse et l'écorce ont besoin que soit
mis définitivement un terme à violence
qui s'appelait fondements même de la
paix sociale sur l'île alors si Je vous
remonte ces images c'est parce qu'elle
vous rappelle forcément quelque chose
parce que à l'époque vous aviez 21 ans
non seulement vous étiez sur place mais
vous êtes monté sur scène et vous avez
tenu un discours de vent Jacques Chirac
lui-même
j'imagine que ça c'est un moment qui
vous a marqué voilà la photo oui on vous
voit on voit avec lui
ça va marquer parce que c'était ma
première expression en public et
forcément en plus devant celui qui était
un peu peut-être pas votre modèle mais
en tout cas que vous admiriez que vous
avez beaucoup inspiré et qui était la
raison pour laquelle je me retrouvais là
et effectivement on m'avait fait la
proposition d'ouvrir ce meeting et c'est
toujours un moment d'émotion que de voir
ces images parce qu'il y avait du monde
il y avait un chapiteau qui avait été
fait exprès pour et je me suis retrouvé
à 21 ans devant plusieurs milliers de
personnes chez moi pour parler de cette
campagne présidentielle si particulière
de 2002 avec Jacques Chirac au premier
rang et avec un ancien député qui est de
vous voir ce jour-là et que vous avez
dit vous vous serez député un jour c'est
ça oui mon prédécesseur
reprises de la première circonscription
de la Corse du Sud avait dit vous serez
député un jour je l'avais répondu il va
falloir quand même que que je fasse mes
preuves avant que j'ai quelques diplômes
il m'avait dit non non vous n'y pourrait
rien vous serez député alors au-delà de
Jacques Chirac son les valeurs de la
droite gaulliste qui vous ont qui vous
ont séduit à 16 ans vous avez pris votre
carte au RPR alors que vos parents ont
voté plutôt pour les nationalistes
corses est-ce que la cause nationalisme
vous attendez un moment vous êtes posé
la question non non puisque au début de
mon engagement à 15 ans j'ai de suite
été
happé par par les idées portées par la
droite gaulliste mais je suis CORSE et
ça c'est
indissociable de mon identité et j'ai
pas besoin d'être nationaliste pour être
plus que d'autres mais mais c'est pas
compliqué de faire de la politique en
Corse aujourd'hui quand on n'est pas
nationaliste vous êtes le seul député
nationaliste aujourd'hui en Corse oui ce
sont des vous savez ce sont des cycles
les nationalistes ont mis des années
avant de réussir à avoir un seul élu ne
serait-ce que dans une mairie parce que
ils étaient rejetés par la population il
y a eu des évolutions vous avez eu
beaucoup de changements dans les
politiques Corse et moi en ce qui me
concerne lorsque je me présente devant
les électrices et des électeurs ça se
passe plutôt bien pour moi peut-être
parce que les discours que je tiens et
les actes surtout qui sont les miens
qu'on vienne et que il n'a pas besoin
d'être nationaliste pour pouvoir être
élu et accepté par la population alors
est-ce que c'est vrai qu'au lycée on
vous surnommé le maire et pourquoi parce
que vous aviez déjà l'ambition de
devenir mère d'Ajaccio ça out parce que
je l'avais dit j'avais dit que je
voulais être mère de la vie un jour
parce que c'est une ville qui m'est cher
que j'aime profondeur personne ne
pensait véritablement que que j'allais
avoir cette forme de constance dans
l'engagement et que ça allait finalement
arriver est-ce qu'on va on va raconter
votre parcours mais effectivement ça
s'est fait étape par étape mais vous y
êtes arrivé alors vous êtes d'abord
devenu députés en 2012 avant d'être
Luère mais dès l'âge de 20 ans vous êtes
donc présenté aux municipales sur la
liste du maire de l'époque qui
s'appelait donc lui aussi Marc Angeli
mais qui est pas vraiment de votre
famille en tout cas assez éloignée si
j'ai bien compris c'était un petit
cousin vous voilà tous les deux nous
sommes connus que dans le cadre de la
vie politique puisque il avait un accord
avec le RPR et moi j'étais candidat en
tant que membre du RP j'avais beaucoup
de cheveux quand même
il est temps le temps passe et donc
voilà j'étais sur le compte agent RPR
vous savez j'étais le benjamin de cette
liste comme ça se voit j'étais assez
jeune puisque je n'avais que 20 ans et
alors 6 ans plus tard vous avez été élu
dans l'opposition vous vous êtes imposé
comme le chef de l'opposition vous avez
travaillé à réunir un peu la droite
d'Ajaccio qui était assez divisé et en
2014 vous avez été élu maire on sent
vraiment la force de votre détermination
pour atteindre vos objectifs c'était
vraiment votre objectif politique je
crois que vous pouvez avoir des
candidats de n'importe quel tendance
qu'il soit lorsque vous aller chercher
une victoire il faut avoir une ferme
détermination ça vient pas seul
surtout quand vous avez une opinion qui
est partagée vous aviez un air sortant
qui était installé depuis 13 ans
les gens sont assez rétifs au changement
lorsque on change de mer alors que le
sortant avec candidat c'est assez rare
et c'est ce qui s'est passé en 2014 à
Ajaccio vous dites que que vous n'avez
pleurer que deux fois en politique le
jour où vous avez été élu maire et le
jour où vous avez su vous allez devoir
renoncer à votre mandat parce que vous
aviez été élu député réélu en 2022 si
vous étiez si heureux dans ce mandat de
mer pourquoi est-ce que vous l'avez
abandonné
parce que c'était le moment il y avait
une situation qui selon moi exigée que
je sois présent ici d'abord parce que la
Corse elle a vécu des moments difficiles
notamment suite à l'agression dans Yves
en Colonna était victime et qu'il a
coûté la vie on a eu des scènes
d'émeutes de violence très grave vous
avez d'ailleurs rédigé un rapport
parlementaire sur des rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête sur l'effet qui
sont produits et parce que je considère
que le lien était en train de se
distendre entre la République et la
Corse à tel point qu'il fallait qu'il y
ait une voie assez forte dans la
majorité présidentielle pour aussi
représenter l'accord c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire depuis un an alors ce
qui vous caractérise aussi c'est un côté
un peu éternel challenger j'en parlais
au début de l'émission à personne ne
croyait en vos chances au législatives
de 2012 finalement vous avez été le seul
sur toute la France à reprendre un siège
de député à la gauche cette année-là en
2014 à Ajaccio vous étiez aussi le
challenger et vous êtes imposé et puis
en 2022 personne n'avait vraiment
anticipé que vous alliez devenir le
Président du Groupe horizon horizon le
parti d'Édouard Philippe est-ce que vous
adversaires n'ont pas tendance un peu à
vous sous-estimer mal leur bras
visiblement mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il
vous sous-estime comme ça je sais pas je
crois que ils sont de moins en moins de
nature à me sous-estimer parce qu'on
voit un peu plus venir maintenant chez
moi et mamie si mais bon pour la
présidence du groupe ça s'est passé
quand même de manière très naturelle les
liens que j'entretiens avec Edward
Philippe sont anciens nous connaissons
depuis 11 ans ce sont des liens qui sont
basés sur l'amitié et également
l'identité de point de vue et lorsque je
me suis présenté à cette élection
interne ça s'est passé plutôt bien mais
ce qu'il y a c'est qu'effectivement les
journalistes les commentateurs n'avaient
pas forcément prévu vous avez pas vu le
scénario ils m'ont pas vu venir
on sent qu'il y a quelque chose de
passionné en vous dans votre rapport à
la politique au point que certains vous
ont reproché d'être un peu trop rude
parfois et vous même vous le
reconnaissiez récemment dans une
interview vous avez dit c'est vrai qu'à
31 ans j'étais beaucoup plus après rude
que maintenant j'étais vraiment dans une
version 1.0 je n'étais pas encore perd
de famille ni mariée vous avez changé on
change tous
calmer enfin à s'agit bien sûr
heureusement d'ailleurs heureusement
qu'on s'agit et puis ensuite on voit la
difficulté des choses on les apprend
d'une autre manière et surtout on
apprend également à faire avec les
autres malgré les différences
parfois j'étais plus connu à plus
punchers je pense que depuis un an en
tant que président de groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale ce qui me
fréquente y compris même mes homologues
voient que je suis plutôt un homme de
dialogue un homme ouvert un homme qui
essaye de discuter avec les autres et un
homme qui essaye de respecter la
fonction et le cadre dans lequel nous
sommes celui de l'Assemblée nationale et
il y a quand même eu cet incident dont
le Canard Enchaîné s'est fait l'écho
c'était au mois de février de cette
année le Canard Enchaîné raconte que
vous avez failli en venir aux mains dans
l'hémicycle avec le député LR Aurélien
Pradier le journal précise que vous avez
menacé de lui casser les dents avec les
huissiers ont dû intervenir vous étiez
vraiment prêt à faire le coup de poing
avec un député comme ça dans l'hémicycle
c'est exagéré des huissiers n'ont pas dû
intervenir ça s'est passé hors séance
dans l'hémicycle mais en suspension je
dirais qu'une seule chose je suis très
courtois
je respecte énormément les autres et
j'attends en retour que les autres en
face de même pour moi ça a pas été le
cas vous pouvez aussi faire preuve d'une
forme de dureté y compris avec vos amis
Jean-Jacques Ferrara qui était votre
suppléant à l'Assemblée en 2012 vous a
succédé comme député en 2017 puisque
vous avez choisi à l'époque de rester
maire d'Ajaccio il y avait le nom cumul
des mandats vous deviez choisir entre
les deux mais en 2022 et ben vous lui
avez repris le siège de façon un peu
brutale il y a pas de place pour
l'amitié en politique selon vous il y
avait surtout pas de place pour prendre
de risque de perdre le siège parce que
ce serait pas trop vous avez sacrifié
une amitié parce que c'était votre ami
ça a été un des moments les plus
difficiles de ma vie politique et de ma
vie personnelle
parce que effectivement il y a pas que
des liens politiques il y a aussi des
liens personnels qui se créent mais à un
moment il y a eu une décision qui a été
prise qui était prise par mois mais qui
n'a pas été prise que par mois il y a eu
des discussions au préalable avec
d'autres moi je n'agis pas sur des coups
de menton
je dirais on pas de son improvisation il
y avait une longue réflexion et je sais
que je sais que j'ai fait du mal à cet
homme pour lequel j'ai vraiment profond
respect mais je peux vous dire avec
certitude vraiment c'est une de la
difficulté de l'élection qui a été la
mienne que ça aurait été plus difficile
si ça avait été l'huile candidat et
qu'on aurait pas trois députés
autonomistes aujourd'hui élu à la fin
des nationales mais 4
votre injecteur politique est suit de
très près celle d'Edouard Philippe vous
en avez parlé un peu vous étiez tous les
deux engagés à droite vos débuts vous
avez tous les deux soutenus Alain Juppé
pendant la primaire vous vous avez
rallié Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui vous
présidez donc le groupe horizon à
l'Assemblée
est-ce que c'est pas un peu comme avec
Jacques Chirac entre vous deux est-ce
que c'est pas une histoire d'homme en
quelque sorte d'admiration de respect
est-ce que vous avez pas besoin de ça
pour vous engager derrière quelqu'un ah
ben si j'avais pas ce rapport à Édouard
Philippe ce rapport de fidélité de
respect
d'admiration parce que je crois vous
avez besoin d'admirer j'ai besoin
d'avoir vraiment confiance comme vous le
voyez je ne me range pas tous les quatre
matins derrière quelqu'un Édouard
philippe est un homme d'une très grande
qualité tant d'un point de vue politique
humaine et ça compte pour moi
on va passer à notre quiz à présent si
vous le voulez bien donc le principe est
simple je commence une phrase et c'est
vous qui devez la compléter ok c'est
parti s'il y a un cliché sur les Corses
que je confirme tu sais si possible ah
oui on est plutôt susceptible un bon
président de groupe doit avant tout
rassembler de rassembler son groupe il
doit rassembler son groupe derrière une
politique sur des textes et sur une
attitude à avoir dans l'hémicycle les
moments dehors enfin en 2027 Édouard
Philippe sera
tu ne sais pas il est le président de la
République vous le souhaitez moi je
pense qu'il a les qualités pour pouvoir
être un bon Président de la République
comme il a été un bon premier ministre
mais ensuite il y a une décision qui
doit être prise par lui et par lui seul
et ensuite c'est le peuple français il
décidera de qui sera le chef de l'État
en 2027 merci beaucoup Laurent
Martinelli d'être venu dans la politique
et moi merci
[Musique]